[Música]
esta semana España inicia oficialmente
su campaña para las elecciones
adelantadas del 23 de Julio cada vez más
las encuestas sugieren que la derecha
podría entrar al gobierno luego del voto
castigo aplicado a Pedro Sánchez en los
comicios pasados para analizar este tema
saludamos en Bogotá a Miguel Gómez
valestreri el spitv en ciencias
políticas y relaciones internacionales y
profesor del departamento de ciencias
políticas de la universidad javeriana en
Colombia señor Gómez Bienvenido a
directo a América Buenos días Cómo estás
después de la derrota del psoe en las
elecciones autonómicas y municipales
hace más de un mes Pedro Sánchez decide
convocar a elecciones anticipadas y así
evitar que la derecha siga
fortaleciéndose de alguna manera Pero
ahora una encuesta del centro de
investigaciones sociológicas pronostica
que la derecha completamente el PP
podría ganar las elecciones pero no le
alcanzaría para gobernar ni siquiera con
los votos del partido vox Cómo cree que
se llegó a estos pronósticos
Bueno yo creo que aquí hay que integrar
una visión de largo plazo y también
multinivel es decir que lo que ha pasado
de las elecciones autonómicas y locales
no significa que forzosamente vaya a
pasar lo mismo a nivel nacional primer
punto segundo punto hay un desgaste
evidente del gobierno Sánchez en estos
años y en un sistema parlamentario como
el español ese tipo de desgaste Pues
lleva reconfiguraciones donde también
algo muy interesante ha sido la caída de
podemos en las intenciones de Voto así
como de su capacidad para pues atraer
electorado entonces ahí por ejemplo
tenemos la aparición de nuevas
plataformas electorales Como por ejemplo
sumar que retoman y desafían a la
izquierda al gobierno de Sánchez
entonces
primer elemento el desgaste tiene que
ver con elementos económicos pero
también con políticas sociales segundo
también tiene que ver con una cierta
frustración por parte de la población
ante ciertas políticas sociales que no
forzosamente han avanzado como se les
habría gustado Como por ejemplo el tema
de sanidad y tercer punto Pues
evidentemente el contexto internacional
entonces diría que el panorama de las
encuestas es relativamente previsible
bien usted mencionaba a sumar de hecho
esta misma encuesta Dice que para que el
psoe pueda retener el gobierno Debería
ser una alianza con esta coalición qué
tan factible es esta posible Alianza
en realidad es bastante factible porque
de hecho hoy día el gobierno de Sánchez
ya tiene ciertos ministros que provienen
de podemos la líder de sumar pues
originalmente venía o provenía de
podemos Pero ha creado una plataforma
nueva diría que en el mundo es
extremadamente plausible mucho más que
hace unos años y aquí hay que retener
algo y es que cuando estamos ante un
sistema parlamentario donde se tienen
que establecer alianzas eh la estrategia
de los gobiernos tradicionales como psoe
y PP puede ser también introducida a los
gobiernos que están o a su izquierda su
derecha para también intentar socavar el
voto protesta que se dirige hacia esos
partidos por ejemplo podemos en su
momento hoy día asomar o por ejemplo vox
para el PP y también al fin y al cabo
los terminan debilitando Por lo cual lo
que hemos visto como alianzas a nivel
subnacional también da pistas de que el
electorado es mucho más móviles decir
que hay en el en el voto de los de los
españoles y no están forzosamente
votando igual a nivel subnacional que a
nivel nacional y segundo punto
importante aquí es el peso en el fondo
ha perdido la iniciativa en términos de
política social porque eso ha sido su
gran bandera en los años 2000 con el
gobierno zapatero y a posteriori porque
en el fondo el pezón no pone en duda la
economía de Mercado cosa que si ponían
duda podemos entonces al zoom al
hacer alianzas con sumar lo que podría
hacer es recuperar también
esa iniciativa en términos de política
social y No dejarse cooptar esa ese
digamos esa arena de la de la discusión
política hablemos de un personaje que
usted acaba de mencionar y es la líder
de sumar esta misma encuesta también
dice que sumar podría ser la segunda
fuerza más votada y aquí sobresale es
esta figura clave que es Yolanda Díaz
Qué posibilidades tiene ya de
convertirse en esta primera presidenta
del gobierno español como ella misma lo
ha manifestado
Bueno yo creo que hay una intención por
su parte Pero la verdad es que el caudal
de Voto que tiene ahora mismo no le
daría para ser la número uno del
gobierno ahora Es evidente que por
ejemplo Pedro Sánchez es un momento
también desafío la tradición de las
investiduras y las alianzas políticas en
España y logró ser presidente del
gobierno ahora lo que hay que tener
claro es esto es algo muy interesante y
es que en España antes teníamos partidos
de opinión que forjaban opinión pública
hoy día tenemos cada vez más y de hecho
por ejemplo más Cómo fue un poco un
ejemplo igual la aparición de
plataformas electorales que lo que hacen
es respaldar ciertos liderazgos Y
entonces esto ya era algo relativamente
normal en las democracias
latinoamericanas pero en España es algo
Hasta cierto punto reciente esto es
estabiliza también el sistema político
español porque fuerza a los partidos
tradicionales a repensarse y también
establecer estrategias muchísimo más
finas a nivel entre los subnacional y lo
nacional para responder a su pregunta en
términos de capacidad de Voto tampoco
hay que presuponer que todos los votos
por ejemplo que ha perdido podemos o que
estaría perdiendo peso es irían
directamente a sumar porque sumar
también está proponiendo una agenda de
gobierno que no forzosamente comience
por ejemplo a las electoras feministas
muchísimo más ambiciosas tampoco
convence a la electorado por ejemplo más
ideológico izquierdas propio de podemos
y tampoco por ejemplo estaría
convenciendo a votantes de psoe más
tradicionales desde los años 80 Bueno
este fin de semana España asumió la
presidencia del Consejo de la Unión
Europea que giro tomaría el mandato
español en caso de que haya un cambio de
gobierno
Bueno yo no tengo bola de cristal en ese
aspecto pero creo que aquí también hay
hay que también decir que las agendas
europeas no dependen forzosamente
digamos no plenamente de quien esté
asumiendo esa presidencia si bien están
marcadas no significa que el rumbo de lo
que se vaya a discutir a nivel europeo
vaya a cambiar forzosamente es sobre
todo en un contexto donde tenemos una
debilidad geopolítica o por parte de la
Unión Europea que está insertada en un
proceso de repensarse y repensar su rol
a nivel internacional pero lo que está
claro es que por ejemplo lo que es el
apoyo a la a Ucrania por ejemplo o lo
que sería una relación que se está
intentando digamos revisitar con China o
con Ucrania con con Rusia o con Irán
pues esos desafíos no van a cambiar
realmente con un cambio de gobierno
español lo que sí hay que aclarar aquí
es que el cambio de gobierno español sí
puede habilitar la iniciativa en algunos
aspectos de lo que sería la agenda de
reforma
las instituciones o los procesos
decisionales dentro de la Unión Europea
pero pues la Unión Europea en el fondo
en términos de generación de política
pública es algo extremadamente técnico y
estable entonces cambia algunos aspectos
y otros no bien era Miguel Gómez Trevi
analista político en relaciones y
ciencias políticas y relaciones
internacionales Muchas gracias por el
análisis aquí en 24 de Cara a estos
comicios en España Gracias a ustedes por
la invitación y ustedes televidentes
también gracias por sintonizarnos en
momentos regresamos hacemos una hora de
pausa esto es directo América
[Música]